david tennant obviously you're part of
the yeah have you ever seen doctor who
gloria
my son lived here a year and a half and
he turned me on to the show and it's
it's amazing i love it
although i think bill and ted ripped you
guys off they did they
yeah that's all right that's a good
reference right yeah yeah
excellent adventures and is this the
doctor who you saw
yes okay she says with confidence
yes it was the only one oh no there's no
only one that's right
but no so doctor who it continues you
see because they
keep regenerating yes yeah if you tune
in now like james bond yeah there's a
different one yeah it's gonna be girls
now
it is it is a woman now and obviously
because it's so top secret who's gonna
be the new
yeah but because you had worked so
closely with jody
on broadchurch did you know did she
confide in you
i knew a little bit before but only
because because chris chibnall who wrote
broadchurch who we both know
is now running doctor who so he phoned
me up and said
um the next doctor would like to call
you is that okay
how excited who is it no no don't worry
don't worry
they'll be the next person to it was it
was
call
it was very high level who yeah doctor
who yeah we know now
yeah brilliant if your mum had snuck in
a call just in between
no you never told me
so then after i put my phone down and
waited for it to ring
and of course because i know jody her
name pops up
and uh it was very exciting wow and uh
oddly you met your wife on the set of dr
who yeah
but she is the daughter of a doctor who
yes which must drive doctor who people
into a frenzy
i mean it is statistically quite
unlikely yeah
um but it oh there we all are look
there's the three of us
yeah oh that's so embarrassing i'm
wearing the seam suit
come on
[Applause]
that doesn't make me look very when
swept and celebrity-tastic
i mean it's a very nice one you wouldn't
want me to just wear it once right
now no no you know you know it works you
know it works
you look lovely but surely there should
only be one tardis
yes but the but the tardis regenerates
in the same way the doctor does it's
it's it's unique to each doctor oh i
thought they just kind of redecorated it
it's changed through time so when i was
in the tardis it looked different
to the one that martin knows matt
knocked through
yeah i really like your tardis though
thanks it's cool
yours is lovely and things like sonic
screwdrivers and stuff do you have your
own
yes yeah his is bigger than mine
nice green is got a bit that comes up
the end and lights up
wrecks cause catherine famously you were
the runaway bride and doctor who
now did you get did you get out
did you did you get special coaching you
guys or was it just gotta
did you also and i was running against
david tennant who's
he's a whipper snapper he's a light run
like that and i was and
he always used very very kindly um
which doesn't sound like you were
afforded the same hospitality
david used to factor in reasons to stop
so i could catch up
oh
[Applause]
someone else on the couch has had a
memorable encounter with nature
now matt smith uh you were i believe we
you were the lady right now were you in
a garden or were you
in a field where were you oh
is it the wasp yes
well i was under a sort of veranda it
was like a moroccan rat this is a while
ago
i might add but i was under a sort of
veranda and we were
you know we we we were we were we were
we were
yes she was on top and i you know you
get an
idea sorry sorry to be crass but anyway
to a very long and terrible stories
thank you graeme
um um what happened was she it's sort of
mid-thrust as it were
this is true it is terribly true i was
stung
i was stung on the ghouls
so i sort of yelped out and she
obviously thought it was incredible
[Applause]
i started hopping around and the bloody
wasp had stoned me on the knackers
who's up next hello oh my god
[Applause]
oh my god
he looks more like you than you do
that's where you're here when yeah
that's not what's your name uh matt
[Applause]
now have you have you made yourself look
like matt smith uh
no i think i was born this way yeah it's
a tragedy isn't it yeah
and where where do you live matt uh
bristol in bristol
yes so close to cardiff yes do you have
a question from outside yes i do
in the children need clip that was shown
um david tennant wears the fez
and i was wondering if any more hats
were involved in the episode and did you
get the fez on john hurt
sorry matt sorry buddy
if you stood face to face it would look
like a vase
i mean he does look very like you
doesn't thank you very much have you
seen him before
no no hi oh hello
what's your name sir stefan stefan and
where are you from los angeles
and have you flown in for this we yeah i
did actually i've been
um flying around the world not to outdo
the girl earlier but
i've been working on a doctor who tattoo
and um
and i've been having all the doctors to
actually sign my arm and have it
tattooed over the ideas to get them all
oh crush um
actually since we're talking about it
wait wait hang on uh uh
stephanie do
yeah i i ambushed you in a hotel lobby
yeah and i was
pissed and i said careful cause i was
drunk
and you actually did it where's matt i
didn't matt's right here
and then uh sylvester mccoy is here and
peter davidson
and i'm actually missing david oh
we actually figured in a spot
specifically for you to sign okay oh
all right what's your name again stefan
okay stefan quickly someone will show
you how to get into the studio run in
quick quick quick
quickly leave your jacket maybe jacket
so uh
tell him about leona maybe he could sign
it somewhere else
oh yes
[Applause]
okay hello stefan hi come on in now uh
this is david tennant
hey this is a good opening incredible
outfit where did you get all this stuff
um this was actually from debenhams i
was lucky enough to get married look at
these treasures they're amazing
it's one of the finest schools so why'd
you go in here yeah that was that was
actually made
special specifically for you mr jimmy
carter wants to ask you a question
what do you think it's gonna be like to
touch a girl
actually i'm i'm uh i'm married to the
dalek
you're married to the dalek of course
you are coursework
[Applause]
i'm kind of nervous yeah
beautifully done thank you thank you
david
uh well done give it around
you